everybody sipping on wrong
and my ties
[Music]
[Music]
oh that is smooth if you like pina
coladas You're Gonna Love what my next
guest is making today and I know singer
Bruno Mars and it looked like Anderson
back there too right oh my gosh they
would approve it includes a celebrate
Rum which he Co they co-own and here to
tell us more about it is their Global
brand ambassador for salvarez Ryan clown
welcome thank you for having us we
really appreciate it it's such a
pleasure to have you and I have heard of
this room tell us a little bit about it
and and how did Bruno and Anderson get
involved in this well so uh first of all
silver Ray which roughly translates to
uh Jungle King
um is these four beautiful bottles and
here is our owner's Reserve these are
four award-winning Cuban style rums
um sustainably made in the jungles of
Panama so they're all single estate now
how was it created uh so it's made from
molasses so yeah so it's a spirit made
from molasses which is the waste from
the sugar refining industry wow and so
we actually create our own molasses so
we do that there at our Distillery we
only boil it over once and so we're
using the best molasses that we can
possibly make I read an article that
Bruno says he really wants to make
roamed sexy and I think just judging
from that video we saw is doing that and
you have a cocktail that you're going to
make us using silver Ray rum tell us
what this is what are we going to do so
this is actually one of the cocktails uh
that we served at the Mayfair Supper
Club okay for New Year's Eve this is
actually one of Bruno's favorite
cocktails it's called the Hollywood
colada oh what's up it's absolutely
delicious so it's actually a riff on a
classic traditional pina colada without
the calories without the cream without
the dairy so we're going to go ahead and
do just a quarter ounce of freshly
squeezed lime juice in here
go ahead and grab my hand for this last
little bit where can we buy silver Ray
so you can get silver Ray at any Total
Wine you can also if you want to go to a
bar any MGM property and you can also
get it at least liquor oh nice yeah yeah
three varieties there yeah so we have
our coconut which is what we'll be
making this cocktail with right now we
also have our chocolate which is the
highest rated flavored spirit in tasting
panel history and our white rum which is
the highest rated white rum and tasting
panel history I've never heard of
chocolate rum before that sounds amazing
coconut one you're using yes got the
molasses so this right here is going to
be our sweetener we're using organic
agave nectar nice all right so we
already have our lime juice now we're
doing our organic agave nectar we're
going to go ahead and add one full ounce
of pineapple juice I'm gonna go ahead
and do two because we're going we're
gonna drink here you're so you're So
Graceful I'm not gonna I'm Not Gonna
Leave You Out on this one and then we're
gonna grab some unsweetened uh coconut
water okay all right and this one right
here we're going to go ahead and do two
ounces so for this cocktail since we're
making two we'll do four all right all
right
got about 30 seconds left I will not
wait to try it all right and then we're
going to go ahead and add our coconut
rum lost the [ __ ] there
that just those bottles are beautiful
I'm so excited these are actually
designed by uh Bruno himself wow yeah
just gorgeous and uh this is uh this is
his favorite because he said it's it's
got the all the flavor but not many of
the calories very clean very sessionable
very easy to drink I love it all right
all right give it a shake
all right
oh my gosh it's all frothy just like a
pina colada absolutely I'm just going to
give that to you so you can give it a
quick taste yeah okay you gotta you
gotta have a drink with me I'm not gonna
do without you all right Cheers Cheers
let's see
the Hollywood colada oh my gosh that's
better than a regular pina colada it
tastes like one too doesn't it yeah this
is fantastic get your silver Ray rum it
is wonderful again at the these liquor
Total Wine MGM properties absolutely
nice thank you so much for joining us
Jillian over to you